in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinhaxadion for June 26 on which we commemorate our righteous
Father David of Thessalonica, this earthly angel and heavenly man renounced his earthly land
of Mesopotamia and all worldly attachment at an early age to take up his cross and follow
the Lord by becoming a monk in the monastery of St. Theodore and Mercurios, generally known
as of the Cucullates in Thessalonica. He mortified the desire of the flesh by a sustained
askecies and was guided in the science of virtue by meditating on Holy Scripture and the lives
of the saints. The holy stylites, Simeon, the elder, Simeon of the wonderful mountain,
Daniel, Potapius, and those like them enjoyed his special admiration and, burning with desire
to imitate them, he climbed up into an almond tree to the right of the church and settled on one of
its branches as a new kind of stylite, dendrite, offering himself as a spectacle to both angels
and men he patiently endured all the rigors of the climate battered by the wind, burned by the sun,
drenched by the rain and exposed to cold and snow during the winter. He was even deprived of the
stability that the stylites enjoyed on their columns and perched on his branch was like a bird
that continually lifted up its voice night and day to God in the sweetest melodies of his prayers
and ceaseless thanks-givings. Devout men full of zeal for virtue became his disciples
and begged him to come down from his perch to become their guide in the monastic life.
David replied that he would only do so after three years if he received a sign from God to so do.
When three years had passed an angel appeared to him and made it clear that he had pleased God by
his manner of heavenly life but that it was now time to descend and to retire to a cell before
being given another mission. David made this message known to his disciples, who, after having prepared
a new dwelling for him, a tiny space, made him get down from his branch. This he did in the presence
of Metropolitan Dorothils of Thessalonica and a large number of clerics.
The divine liturgy was celebrated after which the saint entered into reclusion to the accompaniment
of a spiritual concert of hymns and thanks-givings. Praying continually without distraction,
the saint acquired extraordinary grace and fervor from God. One night, the soldiers who were
keeping guard on the ramparts of the city saw that fire was streaming from his cell.
As soon as morning came, they rushed to the cell but found to their amazement,
but it was completely undamaged and the man of God was safe and sound.
The same miracle happened again and again and the whole population became witnesses of it.
One of the city's inhabitants, Paladios by name, having seen this miracle occur several times,
said to himself, if God accords such glory to His servants on earth, what must be the glory reserved
for them in the age to come when their faces will shine like the sun? He left to become a monk in Egypt.
From this glory of God, which was the object of His contemplation, Saint David received the
power to drive out demons. He also gave sight to the blind and healed all manner of sicknesses
invoking the name of Christ and, in this way, being regarded by the whole town as its guardian angel.
At that time, the combined forces of the Slavs and Avar hordes, who had already ravaged almost the
whole of Macedonia, were threatening Cermium, where the prefect Elyricum was living. He wrote to
Aristides, Metropolitan of Thessalonica, asking him to send a virtuous man as an ambassador to Emperor
Justinian, to ask him for permission to transfer his residence to Thessalonica, where the ramparts of
the city protected it from all the assaults of the barbarians. The clerics and important officials,
whom the bishop gathered together, all cried with one voice, that only David the recluse was able
of representing them before the Emperor. The saint refused at first citing his advanced age,
but remembering the message of the angel, he afterwards submitted, prophesying that he would die
a short distance from his cell on his return. When Saint David came out of his cell, all the people
prostrated themselves on seeing his imposing figure. His hair and beard reached his feet,
and his face was like that of patriarch Abraham, shining with glory.
He set out for Byzantium with two disciples, but the Emperor was away when he reached the palace,
and he was received by Empress Theodora, who asked him to pray for the salvation of the Empire,
and of the city. On his return Emperor Justinian, learning that a man of God was present at the court,
called together the senate, so that it might hear his request. St David picked up live coals
in his hands, and placing incense on them, sensed the Emperor and all the senate for about an hour,
without being at all harmed. The Emperor was greatly impressed, and exceeded to the request
of the Metropolitan which David had presented, that the seat of the prefect of Elicrium be transferred
to Thessalonica, that transfer happened in 535. He then sent David home, showing him great marks of
honor. When the ship came near the lighthouse of Thessalonica, once the saint's monastery could
be seen, David told his disciples that his hour had come, and after giving them the kiss of peace,
and uttering a last prayer, he gave his blessed soul into God's hands, in about the year 540.
Despite a strong wind, the ship came to a halt, and the smell of incense filled the air,
while heavenly voices were heard. When they ceased, the ship continued its journey.
The Metropolitan and all the people were there on the shore to welcome the saint, and he was buried
in his monastery in accordance with his last request. A hundred and fifty years later,
the abbot, wishing to steal part of his relics for himself, had the tomb opened, but the stone which
covered the body, broke it into a thousand pieces. Thirty years later, the next abbot succeeded in
opening the tomb and found the saint's body in corrupt. For centuries, these precious relics
continued to work miracles. Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God,
of mercy on us, and save us.